FACING 48 SHOTS AND THAT WAS THT
OF PLAY.K, YOU BETTER
BE CAREFUL IN YOUR OWN ZONE,
JUST LIKE THIS SITUATI IN THEIR
LINEUP TONIGHT FROM
SHOT.
>> Mickey: OH, WOW.
THAT SURE WAS A GOOD STOP.
NOW OVER FOR RAYMOND AND IN
BEHIND, LARKIN,LOOKING TO TRY TU
INTO TAKING PENALTIES, AN
MATTER WHAT IS GOING ON.
>> Ken: AND CALGARY HAS CHOICES
FOR ON.
[ Whistle ]
>> Ken: AND WHO IS RIGHT THERE,
CENTRE TO GET IT.
RUN INTO ONE ANOTHER WITH
MANGIAPANE KNOCKED DOWN THAT
GOTTEN A LITTLE BIT FANNED ON BY
KYLINGTON AND A SHOT SIDE WITH I
TRYIYI
FRONT OF THE NET AND THAT IS
GOOD COMMUNICATION IN 2013.HAT
THEY'VE TRAILEDE
BEING, WITH 11 FORWARDS AND SO
YOU WILL SEE A LITTLE MIXING, PK
GIORDANO, FORMER CAPTAIN IN
DUBE, FOR CALGARY, HIT BY SMITHR
IT.
THE
MOVING IT QUICKLY.
LINDHOLM WITH THE GAUDREA FOR CY
AND ZADINA HELPING WITH THE
>> Ken: IT WAS ELIASASCK TO LEDN
FRONT, THA OH, FROM POINT BLANK
RANGE AND MARKSTROM WITH THE
STOP ON MO SEIDER A A MARKSTROMS
BEEN LUCAS
3-0HERE.LL REJOIN THD
ERROR.
>> Mickey: AND I CAN TELL THAT
FOURTH LINE WITH MANGIAPANE,
ON COMES RAYMOND. SAVE TO
KEEP THIS PAI
PAID.
>> Mickey:y:
IN FRONT.
AND IT IS CLEARED, TO THE LINE,
BUT NOT OUT.
LEDDY,
NIGHT.
BAD BOUNCES ALL OVER